I'm more excited by the fact that this
is worth quarter of a million pounds
than by the fact that it's a
thermocouple
this is I think the first sample of
metallic rhodium that I've ever held in
my hands and it's not very thick it's
just a tiny piece of foil but I'm here
at the Johnson Matthey noble metals
processing plant where they turn the
sponge that comes from mines the rhodium
sponge into rhodium metal but rhodium
metal is rarely used by itself it's
usually used as an alloy and this is one
of the few applications of rhodium metal
where it is used as a very very thin
foil for filtering x-rays for cancer
diagnosis particularly breast cancer
this is some sort of wheel that goes
round in front of the x-ray source and
one of the paddles has rhodium on it
rhodium is almost the rarest of the
metals the world production of rhodium
each year is about 20 tons and most of
that rhodium goes into the automotive
catalysts the catalyst that you have on
cars and other vehicles and it catalyzes
a really rather boring reaction but a
very important one which is nitrogen
oxides NO x going to nitrogen and oxygen
and without rhodium catalysts the air
quality in our cities would be much much
worse because of the car exhausts but
rhodium is used in all sorts of alloys
where rhodium mixed with platinum gives
so much better chemical performance here
for example this is thermocouple wire
which is platinum with 13% rhodium in it
where the addition of rhodium makes it
perform much better as a thermocouple
and you can see it really doesn't look
very different from platinum itself
though apparently the people who work
here become really tuned to the
different metals and they can see subtle
differences here is thermocouple
with 30% to rhodium in it and it's all
rep wrapped up from sipping so you can't
actually see inside looks like fishing
line but I'm assured that there's 30%
rhodium in here so we'll have to trust
them I've now got 6% rhodium and
platinum though I must say I'm more
excited by the fact that this is worth
quarter of a million pounds than by the
fact that it's a thermocouple but you
can see if we focus on the science that
this is a thermocouple wire for
measuring temperature weighs over eight
kilos so that's really quite a serious
weight so this is 94% platinum and 6%
rhodium it's very heavy I'm going to put
it down particularly because I'm not
wearing reinforced shoes so another
application for rhodium platinum is in
heart pacemakers I've never seen a
pacemaker before it's not very heavy but
still quite big to go inside one's chest
so a heart pacemaker produces an
electrical signal that helps people's
hearts beat in a regular way those
people who need them if they didn't have
them their heart would tend to flutter
and wouldn't pump in a nice regular way
so here the rhodium is in these very
fine wires that are inside this plastic
coating and these fine wires are the key
to the whole machine they take the
electrical signals to where they needed
to make your heart work this part here
is just batteries and electronics it
doesn't actually do anything for you
it's the electrical signals that come
out at the end that is the key part the
reason it's called rhodium is because it
comes from the Greek word meaning red or
pink because when it was first
discovered William Hyde Wollaston
noticed that the color of the salts were
rather striking reddish color
in fact he discovered palladium and
rhodium was an impurity which he only
discovered when he'd already started
selling palladium as the product but he
was the first person
to isolate it and to give it its name
rhodium itself looks I think like the
other platinum metals a silverish color
iridium is sometimes slightly yellow and
osmium is a rather nice bluish color
it's the only blue metal I think there
is